Transcriber: Nadera Shehabaddin
المدقّق: Mujtaba Abdelwhab
السلام عليكم .
لجنة يعمى كأحد الحلول
ودشنا لما
كشف عنه
طيب .
حصل يوم
سالت روحك أن المكانيكي الي بيصلح
العربية دي عنده شهادة ولا ما عنده
ولا النجار
ولا السباك
عشان نعرف أهمية ناس كثيرة
في حياتنا ومن بينهم التقني
فالعالم الان يمر ويتمتع
بحرية انتقال واسعة جدا جدا
في الخدمات والسلع والافراد
و للمنافسة في الأسواق الداخلية والخارجية
لا بد من
توفير القوة البشرية
وبكافأة ومهارة عالية جدآ جدآ
ولذلك
التعليم
التقني
هو نمط من أنماط
التعليم النظامي
إلا أنه يعتمد وينتج
عمال مهارة بتخصصات مختلفة
ويتضمن المعرفة والتقانة الحديثة
كل الدول
التي استخدمت العمليات والبحوث العلمية
في التعليم النظامي والتقني
الآن نهضت وو صلت الى الدول العظمى
أو الى الدول المتقدمة
في الاربعة وتسعين
دولة اليابان
استخدمت نموذج أو دراسة بإدخال
التعليم الإلكتروني في المدرسة
الابتدائية والثانوية
وفي ثلاثة وتسعين أجريت
الولايات المتحدة الامريكية
دراسة بإدخالها برضه ، وأيضا
التعليم الالكتروني في المرحلة الابتدائية
متوسط
كل ثمانية تسعين
قصاد كلي
سبع فصول
يكون في جهاز الكتروني
واحد
منذ عام ١٩٩٣
فالآن كلنا نعلم
ما وصلت إليه هذه الدول
كذلك في القارة الأفريقية
الدول التي نهضت نهضت وسلكت
الطريق
في نفس الوقت
دول آسيا على سبيل المثال
عندنا تجربة الهند .
في وفي مواجهتها للبطالة استخدمت لينا
برضه الأعمال الحرفية والتقنية
وعندنا تجربة ماليزيا
فنحن في السودان نمر بفترة حساسة جدا جدا في
عدم كفاية أنماط التعليم الحالية وتنوعه
وكفايتها مع مخرجات العملية التعليمية أدى
الى خلل في إنه بذلك أن جماعة غالبية
غالبية الخريجين يعانوا
من تنفيذ الاعمال بجودة عالية جدا جدا
فلذلك انا اتمنى من انه
كل الدراسات الموجودة حاليا تهتم
بجزء لا بتجزا
من التعليم التقني والحرفي الموجود
لأن دولة باسودان بالموارد
والثروات الموجودة
لا يمكن أن تهدر أو يغيب فيها في
في تجارب
حصلت في السودان منذ السبعينيات وفي معاهد
كثيرة جدا لليله كاعد تخرج
في تقنيين وفي عمال مهارات
ولكن
عدم مواكبة العالم وعدم تأهيل الكادر أو
الأستاذ الذي يدير هذه المراكز أدى إلى ضعف
الإنتاج في نفس الوقت ، بذلك أنه حاليا في
تعدد مصادر في ريادة الأعمال الحرفية
والتقنية
فتعدد هذا اذا وضعنا له نحنا معايير
بتاعت تاهيل
ومواصفات بتاعت تاهيل, بياخذنا الى نتائج
والنتائج لواحدة منها
بتحقق لنا اقتصاد يكون قائم
على التنوع في التخصصات بيوفر لنا
اقتصاد قومي وفردي نكدر ننافس
به داخليا وخارجيا ، بذلك أن
الاهتمام بالتعليم التقني يحقق نتائج على
مستوى البنية التحتية والتنمية المتوازنة
بذلك إنه النتائج بتاعت الاهتمام بالتعليم
والتدريب التقني يقودنا
إلى أنه يخرج لنا جيل
وتنمية تكون قائمة على
المعرفة والتقانة الحديثة
فلذلك ضرورة توفير البيئة
المساندة للمجتمع ، عشان ينمو ويزدهر
اجتماعيا واقتصاديا وتكنولوجيا
هل تعلم أنه الآن في أبحاث يابانية أو
دراسة يابانية تجرى ؟ إنه عايز يعمل
اصنصير يربط ما بين الأرض والقمر يشتغل
بحاجة اسمها النانوسانية أو الساعة الذرية
أين نحن من هذه العلوم ومن
هذه التقانات ؟ فلذلك
ب
نوصي أن
في الفترة جاية أنا اتمنى من أن ضرورة
الاعتماد على رأس المال البشري والفكري
القائم على التنوع وعلى
المهارة العالية جدا جدا
أنه نتيح الفرص للناس عشان تنمي
وتزيد أو تغير من مهاراته لكي نقدر
لنزدهر و نواكب العالم
في الختام
أنا الى هنا
بيكون فرصتي انتهت
وكلامي يكون خلص
فأنا أتمنى من أنه
قدرت ان اوصل المعلومة
وكل زول فينا يقدر ينمي روح لابتكاره
وروح المحاورة داخله
والجيل الجاي
ينهض وينمو
تفنيا وتكنولوجيا ومعلوماتيا
والسلام عليكم ورحمة الله تعالى وبركاته .